PETE: IT’S A BEAUTY.
JILLIAN: LOVE IT.
PETE: WELL DONE.
LET’S BRING IN CALIFORNIA GOP
CONGRESSMAN DEVON NUNES RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE WAYS AND
MEANS COMMITTEE I DON’T KNOW IF
HE CAN PLAY GUITAR, BUT
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US ON THIS EASTER
WEEKEND.
WE WANT TO GO TO CAPITOL HILL,
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE, THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HE WANT, A TARGETED SMALL
BUSINESS PACKAGE, MAYBE PAYROLL
TAX RELIEF, INFRASTRUCTURE BILL,
WHAT’S POSSIBLE, WHAT ARE YOU
GUYS AIMING FOR HERE?
>> WELL THE REAL NEED TO
SENATOR MCCONNELL TRIED TO GET
PASSED THIS WEEK WAS JUST A
PLUS-UP TO THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE PROGRAM LOANING
MONEY TO BUSINESSES SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PAY EMPLOYEES, SO
THAT THEY DON’T HAVE TO GO ON
THE UNEMPLOYMENT ROLES.
WANT TO LOAD IT UP, WITH A LOT
MORE JUNK, WHICH WE KNOW THEY
DID LAST TIME, YOU MAY RECALL,
THEY GOT MONEY FOR THE KENNEDY
CENTER AND LAST TIME I CHECKED,
IT’S NOT BEING BUILT INTO SOME
HOSPITAL TO HANDLE COVID
PATIENTS, SO LOOK, IT’S
UNFORTUNATE, BUT AT THIS POINT,
I THINK THE KEY IS GOING TO BE
WHEN DO WE GET THE COUNTRY BACK
TO WORK, AND PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY CAN GO BACK TO WORK.
WE’RE STARTING TO SEE STATES
LIKE TEXAS THAT DEVELOP THEIR
OWN PLAN, HOPEFULLY OTHER STATES
WILL FOLLOW SUIT, ALONG WITH
CITIES AND COUNTIES SO THAT WE
CAN GET AMERICA BACK TO WORK AND
IN THE MEANTIME, WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
PASSED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO ARE
FULLY FUNDED SO THAT THE
AMERICANS, EVERY AMERICAN
THAT WANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM, IN FACT, CAN.
JILLIAN: YOU MENTIONED THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING
AMERICA BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE IS
ASSEMBLING ANOTHER TASK FORCE
FOCUSED ON REOPENING OUR ECONOMY
IN YOUR OPINION WHO NEEDS TO BE
A PART OF THAT TASK FORCE, WHAT
TYPE OF MINDS?
>> WELL WHAT I WOULD SAY ON
THIS IS THAT THE BEST WAY WE CAN
HANDLE THIS IS CLOSEST TO THE
PEOPLE, SO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS STEPPING IN WHERE
WE CAN, WHETHER IT’S THROUGH
THIS PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
, OR  WHETHER IT’S WITH
MASKS AND OTHER EQUIPMENT, THE
VENTILATORS BUT THE WAY
WE’RE GOING TO FIX ALL OF THIS
IN THE LONG RUN IS BE ABLE
TO HANDLE THESE OUTBREAKS
QUICKLY, SO ONE OF THE KEYS TO
THAT IS GOING TO BE MAKING SURE
THAT EACH AT THE COUNTY LEVEL OR
THE CITY LEVEL DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF YOUR COUNTY OR  THE
SIZE OF THE CITY THAT YOU
LIVE IN, WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE’S A PLACE THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IF YOU COME
UP POSITIVE, WITH THE VIRUS,
THAT YOU CAN GO TO THAT FACILITY
IF YOU NEED TO BE EITHER 1)
TESTED OR  2) IF YOU HAVE TO
SPEND SOME TIME IN THE HOSPITAL.
WHAT WE DO KNOW ABOUT THIS NOW
IS THAT IT’S A VERY CONTAGIOUS
VIRUS, PROBABLY ONE IN MODERN
HISTORY PROBABLY MOST CONTAGIOUS
VIRUSES, BUT AT THE SAME TIME, A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T HAVE TO GO
TO THE HOSPITAL, WHICH IS A GOOD
THING, SO EVEN THOUGH WE’RE
PREPARED FOR THAT NOW, IN THE
LONG RUN WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LOOK AT WHAT ARE THOSE PLANS,
AND LOOK PETE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT
THIS , WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS A
LOT LIKE A MILITARY OPERATION,
WHICH PETE BE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
GRIFF: YEAH, CONGRESSMAN LET ME
JUMP IN FOR A SECOND BECAUSE YOU
TALK ABOUT RESPONDING AND I WANT
TO THINK A LITTLE BIT TO THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
BECAUSE IT APPEARS NOW THAT HAD
THEY DECLARED THIS A PANDEMIC EL
YES, SIR, HAD THEY NOT BEEN
TELLING US THAT HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSITION WAS IMPOSSIBLE
ACCORDING TO CHINESE SCIENTISTS
THAT WE COULD HAVE RESPONDED
QUICKER, AND NOW, THERE ARE
CALLS FOR THE HEAD OF THE  WHO
TO EITHER RESIGN OR
TESTIFY, WHERE DO YOU COME DOWN
>> WELL LOOK, ALL OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS, THEY ARE ALL DO-
GOOD ORGANIZATIONS, THEY ALL
MEAN WELL, AND THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THEY BECOME VERY BLOATED
AND VERY POLITICAL.
I ACTUALLY, TWO OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION MANY YEARS
AGO I TOURED IT AND QUITE
FRANKLY I WALKED OUT OF THERE
SAYING MY GOD I HOPE WE NEVER
HAVE A PANDEMIC BECAUSE I DON’T
THINK THESE GUYS WILL BE ABLE TO
HANDLE IT.
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE HERE IS IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY’RE TAKING THE
SIDE OF CHINA IN THIS , AND
LOOK, I’M NOT TRYING TO BE ANTI-
CHINA OR  ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WANTS
TO TRY TO ACCUSE PEOPLE OF BUT
LOOK THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
IS DEFINITELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL OF THIS , AND ALONG
WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WHO ESSENTIALLY
ACTED AS KIND OF LETTING THEM DO
THIS AND NOT DOING THEIR ACTUAL
JOB AND I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE EXPECT FOR PEOPLE TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE ESPECIALLY THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE SEND
THERE EVERY YEAR.
GRIFF: VERY QUICKLY JUST TO
FOLLOW-UP ON THAT BECAUSE THE
TIMELINES, WILL CONGRESS BE
TAKING ACTION?
WILL YOU SEEK TO TAKE ACTION TO
HOLD THE  W. H. O. ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WELL YOU’VE HEARD THE
PRESIDENT, HE SAYS HE’S
GOING TO WITHHOLD FUNDS, HE CAN
DO THAT, HE HAS A RIGHT TO DO
THAT, CONGRESS SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT, HOWEVER YOU
KNOW WE’VE ALREADY SEEN THE
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES, SO THEY CAN
BLOCK BUT I THINK THAT ALL
REPUBLICANS ARE UNITED, THAT WE
WANT ANSWERS, NUMBER ONE, FROM
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
AND NUMBER TWO, WE WANT ANSWERS
FROM THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
PETE: IT’S SHOCKING THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE BIPARTISAN,
CONGRESSMAN.
THE DEMOCRATS WOULDN’T WANT THAT
TOO, THEY SAY THEY WANT A 9/11-
STYLE COMMISSION, IT OUGHT
TO BE ABOUT THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CLARITY ON
THAT.
I WANT TO GET TO YOUR COMMENTS
OUR OWN LAURA INGRAHAM DID A
THREE-PART INTERVIEW FANTASTIC
WITH THE A.G. WILLIAM BARR AND
ONE OF THE THINGS HE TALKED
ABOUT IS THERES SOMETHING FAR
MORE TROUBLING ABILITY THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
WATCH WHAT HE SAYS AND WE’LL GET
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE STATE OF JOHN DURHAM’S
INVESTIGATION?
>> MY OWN VIEW IS THAT THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT WE’RE
NOT DEALING WITH JUST MISTAKES
OR  SLOPPINESS.
THERE’S SOMETHING FAR MORE
TROUBLING HERE, AND WE’RE GOING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT, AND
IF PEOPLE BROKE THE LAW, AND WE
CAN ESTABLISH THAT WITH THE
EVIDENCE, THEY WILL BE
PROSECUTED.
PETE: THIS HAS BEEN BEHIND THE
HEADLINES BECAUSE OF
CORONAVIRUS BUT WHAT DO YOU KNOW
, SIR?
>> WELL WE JUST SAW LAST NIGHT,
THERE WERE REDACTIONS THAT WERE
FINALLY REBUILT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, SO THERE’S FOOTNOTES
THAT NOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
BEGINNING TO LEARN MORE.
YOU KNOW THAT THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS HAVE SENT OVER EIGHT
CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE EXPECT THOSE TO BE MONITORED,
LOOKED AT, EVALUATED.
WE KNOW THAT DURHAM IS RUNNING
THIS INVESTIGATION, BUT THE KEY
IS GOING TO BE, YOU KNOW, CAN
YOU BUILD THE EVIDENCE IN ORDER
TO MAKE PROSECUTIONS AGAINST
THERE’S A WHOLE BUNCH OF FOLKS
THAT WE REFERRED BUT THE EIGHT
REFERRALS THAT WE’VE DONE BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT PEOPLE SHOULD GO
AND LOOK AT THOSE FOOTNOTES THAT
ARE NOW PUBLIC, OKAY?
BECAUSE LIKELY, WE’RE GOING TO
HAVE MORE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
BASED ON THESE, AND SO WHAT WE
KNOW NOW, THE BOTTOM LINE IS
WHAT WAS REBILLED LAST NIGHT IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WERE SPREADING DISINFORMATION,
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION WHICH WE
HAVE BEEN SAYING THE WHOLE TIME.
IT NEVER MADE SENSE THAT YOU’D
HAVE A POLITICAL OPERATIVE, LIKE
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WORKING
WITH FUSION GPS, HIRING A
FOREIGN FORMER FOREIGN SPY, THAT
THEY KNOW IS SUPPOSEDLY GETTING
INFORMATION FROM RUSSIAN INTEL
FOLKS?
THAT DOESN’T PASS THE STRAIGHT
FACE TEST.
PETE: INTERESTING.
A LOT MORE TO COME THE WORK
CONTINUE, CONGRESSMAN DEVON
NUNES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR